foreign
what is it like to live in witness
protection well that's the life now
facing the key witness who helped police
convict the merseyside drug dealer who
shot and killed nine-year-old Olivia
Pratt Corbell in her own home the
defendant went to the home of the woman
who was brave enough to come to court to
give evidence against him
Thomas Cashman had been having an on off
affair with this woman and after he'd
shot Olivia he turned up at her house
the defendant invented a defense
designed to humiliate and undermine her
it did not work
but her courage comes at a huge cost
this woman now faces a lifetime of
anonymity and living in the shadows
there are thousands more like her in the
UK but it's a secretive world we know
little about I'm Sally Lockwood and on
this Sky News Daily we'll hear from Rhys
who lived in Witness Protection
we had to leave everything in our house
behind apart from claws I mean my mum
had no baby pictures of me whatsoever
left had no sentimental stuff like
literally lost everything
but first let's hear from Sky News crime
correspondent Martin brunt who covered
the Thomas Cashman murder trial and can
explain just how important this key
witness was
vitally important to a prosecution case
that really was quite weak there wasn't
a great deal of what you might call
traditional direct evidence there was no
eyewitness nobody who could identify
Thomas Cashman as the gunman police
never found the weapons there was no
real forensic evidence to convince a
jury so the testimony of this woman was
vital and she was a very very strong
woman who admitted that by giving
evidence the whole process had ruined
her life the very fact that Cashman had
turned up within minutes of the shooting
but her house had roped her in she got
caught up in it but she was determined
to do the right thing I've done Joey
those words that this woman overheard
Thomas Cashman saying on the phone was
essentially it became the Smoking Gun in
this case is that right Martin and and
explain why this witness had to give
evidence anonymously the witness
overheard Cashman on the phone saying I
they've done Joey the man he had been
chasing and trying to kill that night
was a man called Joseph knee a fellow
Liverpool criminal those words I've done
Joey were interpreted by the prosecution
and displayed in court as a confession
to the shooting the woman gave evidence
anonymously because
she lives within this tight-knit
community she was giving evidence
against one of her own not just one of
her own but a man with whom she had had
an affair she was terrified of
Retribution for giving evidence against
Thomas Cashman we understand that she's
been moved out of Liverpool it's not
clear whether she is now living in the
witness protection scheme merseyside
police have said only that they are
supporting her we do know that she has
been granted lifelong anonymity so
although we know who she is and of
course a lot of people on the estate and
within that Community know her identity
we are not by law allowed to reveal it
she said during her evidence that this
whole episode had ruined her life
um and I think it's quite easy to
understand how and why it's done that do
we know how at risk this woman might be
now having given evidence like this I'm
sure she's at Great risk police sources
suggest that Thomas Cashman uh is a much
feared gangster was a much feared
gangster in that part of Liverpool so
anybody giving evidence against him
would understandably feel vulnerable and
it's been reported that she has been
given more death threats than any other
protected witness on merseyside for many
years the information about what happens
to this woman now won't be made public
Martin but what are her choices likely
to be she does face a very difficult
life if she wants to maintain her
anonymity if if she has been given a new
name and identity and a whole back story
uh that's something that she and her
family are going to have to learn
and learn to keep to I mean the problem
is for a lot of people who enter the
witness protection scheme they don't
really know what to expect and they find
life very difficult and just outline if
you can Martin what we know about how
witness protection Works in this country
what those people go through I know a
lot of it is is very secretive
well by its very nature it's difficult
to find out exactly what happens to
people who go into the witness
protection scheme there are very
different levels of protection that's
offered and it's always a voluntary
thing it would mean broadly moving away
from the area you've been living in with
your family with your close family a new
identity a new back story because one of
the difficulties people face is when
they make new friends they have to have
a story to explain what they've been
doing for the previous years and they
have to learn it and stick to it because
to make a mistake can cause obvious
obvious problems but there are little
things like you know if you FaceTime
relatives from your new location you
have to be careful about removing
anything in the background uh birthday
times particularly for kids that's very
difficult because if anybody's trying to
find you all they have to do is monitor
to a relative who might be posting
something birthday cards all of those
kind of things have to be very very
carefully monitored by you and your
protectors the
damn criticisms of the system in the
past as well Martin just explain about
how it's changed one particular case the
sterlens were a couple whose son uh had
committed a murder in Nottingham another
city with a big criminal underworld
their son had shot the friend of a
gangster
and the couple found very quickly
afterwards there was gunfire at their
house they had to move out of Nottingham
they moved twice in fact but within a
year they were tracked down and shot
dead in their new home the criticism at
the time this was in the um the early
2000s was that the various police forces
involved there where they lived and
where they moved to had not properly
shared intelligence about the
vulnerability of this couple and what it
led to was a broadening of the witness
protection scheme to a national basis
really the National Crime agency or at
least it's Forerunner the serious and
organized crime agency set up a national
scheme at least for England and Wales as
a separate one in Northern Ireland and
Scotland and the Mets but a national
scheme was implemented which meant that
overall responsibility for people in the
system came under one organization so
there were better codes of practice
better standards and so on
I can remember it quite clearly still to
this day and I just remember coming in
my house and
walking in the front door working up the
stairs then when I walked in there was
these two kind of tall men and big suits
and there was all these killer bags
packed and my mum was kind of there and
they just looked at that
worried in a sense I guess I didn't
really know what was going on at this
point I just knew that we were leaving
now re-slipped in witness protection for
several years from around the time he
started High School he told us his story
we went to a hotel and dad feel it at
the beginning
I didn't really know what was going on I
was confused I just was enjoying kind of
go to hotels and been somewhere
different I guess at first and then
obviously it started to not kind of end
I think when it doesn't end you start to
click on and my mom did eventually tell
me as well because obviously a big part
of the decisions and witness protection
doesn't just affect how it affects me it
affects all of us as a whole explain to
us why your mum got put into witness
protection she was basically coming home
from work one time and she was just
driving home and she stopped at a set of
traffic lights wrong place kind of wrong
time and a guy came up and tried to like
get her car instead of the Y and as that
happened another car pulled up and shot
him and it can align it over my mom's
kind of Bonnet of the course so my mom
became a kind of main Witness
my mom was a kind of person I guess
didn't really want to go into this
protection because she was quite a rough
person so she wasn't like the easiest
person to scare I would say so she did
whatever they backed down from it and
she kind of didn't want to leave at
first
um so she kind of tried to kind of not
leave and then she kind of started
getting like phone calls from private
numbers giving her threats about stuff
that's going to happen to her but what
was it like for you being in witness
protection did you feel scared at all
you know that it can be
quite dangerous to be involved in those
kind of situations I guess when I became
aware of it more yeah I was kind of
scared for me but morally for my mom you
just don't know what's going to happen
day to day when you're at school and
stuff did you ever have your safety
compromised did anyone was there any
suggestion that your identity had been
revealed or your location I do remember
having to move quite a lot at one point
and it was just like hotel for three
weeks hotel for three weeks apartment
for a month another house for I mean it
was just all over for a while they
obviously tried their hardest to keep as
much as they could from me but obviously
being there 24 7 it was kind of hard to
keep a lot from me what do you have to
change what do you have to leave behind
for me my mom specifically
um we obviously chose to stay on level
two which meant we didn't get a full new
identity we don't move country Etc so
for us we had to leave our house behind
we had to leave everything in our house
behind apart from clothes I mean my mum
had no baby pictures of me whatsoever
left had no sentimental stuff like
literally lost everything she wasn't
allowed to pretend to your house
whatsoever we weren't allowed to contact
any friends or family for I can't
remember how long it was specifically
but I'm sure at the start it was at
least a year or two maybe and we weren't
meant to be allowed to go near our old
area and what was it like making new
friends did you have to
you know to have a new story about where
you'd come from did you have to have a
new name would that have to change your
name and witness protection when we were
moving around different hotels and
apartments
um at the beginning for a while and I
remember my name being Max because my
mum was really bad uh remembering until
yesterday we were in hotels say both
names at different points but when we
actually moved into like a house and
kind of settled a bit more and I got
settled at the school I was just using
my normal name I think from what I can
remember it was that we were going to
make up a story event we just weren't to
talk or tell anyone why we'd moved
really or what we were involved in apart
from certain people and I found it
really difficult to
and I think I was I became very closed
off from a lot of people and I just
became very angry and very better and
very kind of lashing out a lot
I was going to ask you that next
actually you know what was the impact on
you and on your mum having to live like
this it was difficult because I was just
kind of finding out different things as
it was happening so at first I wasn't
feeling aware of it and then next minute
I'm told right you know when it's
protection that's how that happens
they're kind of life's in danger
it was difficult
I think as well I started to notice my
anger from about age 11. so I guess I
became without realizing it very like
everybody stay away from me so yeah it
really impacted me
now we see witness protection play out
in crime dramas how accurate is it
depending on what the drama is it tends
to glamorize witness protection to an
extent and that is pretty removed from
the Jerusalem afraid uh witness
protection scheme is secure yes safe yes
glamorous it is not
Simon McKay is a barrister who's advised
the government on Witness Protection
it's often one of the most challenging
aspects of it when people are introduced
to it their perception is this is quite
uh you know sexy uh and exciting and
very often for the first few days it
might be
um but the uh those factors tend to
third quite quickly and people get into
the routine and
mundane routines of life
and that's what it becomes much more
challenging forward very often
individuals think that in some way share
performance is going to be an
improvement on their existing life it is
never that indeed the police will will
generally attempt to
represent their new life as it was in
their old life so you know if the
individuals living in a bed sit above a
you know take away on a High Street
Suburban High Street as a general rule
they're going to be moving into a
similar environment what are the biggest
challenges of keeping someone safe in
witness protection
licensee so they go into the scheme
and because the officers that deal with
this uh very often experienced and good
at what they do the confidence that the
person going into the scheme has in
their safety is often a given so within
two or three weeks
they can become a little bit complacent
and assume that everything is okay and
that they're no longer going to be at
risk and sometimes they themselves can
start to take some unnecessary risks
that can place them back in Jeopardy
it's an entirely voluntary scheme so the
police cannot compel someone to stay in
the scheme if they don't want to to stay
in the scheme they can't prevent people
from using social media they can't even
prevent people from having contact with
their family and that's another one of
the big challenges that's a very very
difficult situation for someone to find
themselves in particularly uh someone
young one of the most controversial uh
witness protection cases was the
girlfriend of Stephen Cameron Stephen
Cameron was murdered by the kind of
Underworld criminal figure of Kenny Noy
um he he murdered Stephen Cameron on a
on a slip Road off the M25 and his
girlfriend Daniel cable was obviously a
key witness in the case
she's still in this game another
well-known case is um The Killers of of
James Bulger the toddler who was who was
murdered in merseyside uh back in well
the 90s
Robert Thompson and John venables they
were given new identities after their
release back into society but that's not
been without his problems has it now you
see the other side of the coin of course
so these were the offenders uh who are
released back into the community and
have to have new identities as a result
they're not the only ones Mary Bell as
another example and many other child
Killers who are subsequently released to
have new identities because of the
general public outrage surrounding their
offending
um but it is uh it's extremely difficult
it's extremely difficult to manage and
the one thing I haven't mentioned so far
is the huge psychological pressure on
individuals I mean if you think about it
in a national security context
informants working against terrorist
targets like uh Al-Qaeda or even because
it's back in the Press again Northern
Irish terrorism when these individuals
are compromised very often they've been
living dual lives anyway and then the
threat arises and they're plucked out of
their existence and and you know without
any opportunity to
you know process it or tell people
what's going on how hard is it to find
someone once they've been given a new
identity in this way the Police Service
are very very good the biggest
vulnerability
is not the organized criminals who might
try and seek them out biggest
vulnerability is always the protected
person
who can get complacent can get careless
he's just sick of their life you know
and just yearns for some contact with um
their former loved ones family and
friends and how much more complicated
has social media made things
most of us have a digital footprint
and it's um it's very compelling for
people to want to be on social media and
map out what they're doing with their
life and that's not to say you can't
have social media within the confines of
witness protection you can but the
obvious risk of compromise exists when
people are taking selfies or they're
taking pictures of of their family you
know organized criminals have pretty
sophisticated
and whilst the system is difficult for
them to infiltrate and to um to
undermine
what they can do is begin to put the
jigsaw together or where an individual
is using social media and there are
Clues within the posts there
that they're leaving uh this will
facilitate very often organized
criminals to jigsaw jigsaw the pieces
together which can often lead a trail to
where those individuals are located
reflecting on it now Rhys I mean you're
26 years old now it's 10 years on since
you left Witness Protection
how would you say it's impacted your
life I've
dated people for the last six years and
I would say that I've really started
engaging in support when I was 20 and
that's when I made the proper kind of
changes more so I've been working at it
for six years and I still definitely
have a lot of issues and sometimes I can
overreact and sometimes I can be over
the top some things I can lash out but
it's just about understanding that
that's all comes from trauma and what
I've been through and that you just need
to keep working at it and eventually as
time goes on it gets less and less
and you get better and you get better
thank you to Martin Reese and Simon and
to you for listening to the Sky News
Daily with me Sally Lockwood
this episode was produced by Annie Joyce
with Alex Eden our editor is Paul
stanworth